the morning after what the taliban is
calling a historic victory over foreign
invaders after 20 years of war
wearing u.s military fatigues and
holding american weapons taken from
afghan army depots
taliban special forces are in control on
the tarmac at kabul international
airport
destroyed and abandoned aircraft stand
in what remains of the nato base
no afghans will surrender to force the
way americans left afghanistan is a good
lesson for the future generation they
were damaged financially it's a good
lesson for everyone else it's a historic
day with no doubts it's a free country
it's a sovereign country
america was defeated they could not
achieve their targets through military
operations and on behalf of my nation we
want to have good relations with the
rest of the world
but there is little if any trust on
which those good relations can be built
for the time being at least taliban
leaders say the movement has changed it
promises inclusive governance women's
rights according to the group's own
interpretation of islam it promises a
free media and the right for anyone to
leave the country afghans including
taliban supporters say they want action
not words
whenever a new government is formed it
has to prove itself to the rest of the
world and we are worried what if the
taliban can't my children are anxious
that they won't be able to go out and
live their lives or be involved maybe in
politics and civil society
crowds of people gather outside kabul's
banks many withdrawing the last salary
they will ever receive from a
western-backed government that no longer
exists a government widely accused of
corruption and mismanagement
the challenges are immense especially
when billions of dollars of funding and
afghan cash remains frozen by the west
since the taliban took control women
here say they want the same
opportunities as men no matter any
expected changes to the law
i don't have a problem wearing a burka
as long as their security and justice is
just a piece of fabric they have said
that men and women will be separated at
work well that's okay too i will work
the taliban says give us a chance they
say it is the first day of a new
afghanistan after 20 years of foreign
interference and occupation the wider
world may have no choice but to engage
with the new leaders of this country if
peace and stability is to prevail
charles stratford al jazeera kabul